[Music]
it's midday there's some empty takeout
cups in the frame and asmingold is live
on twitch what's up y'all it's me
it's your boy asmongold he's giving his
opinion on the news of the day and chat
is feeding into it entertainment's a
waste of time bill don't you know that
you've been wasting people's time for 30
[ __ ] years
what are you sitting here getting pissed
off about because people are watching
watching twitch and after a brief detour
into the wild world of reddit asthma
jack-o-lantern challenge what is why
it's time to log into world of warcraft
world first hogger here we go
yes dude or
at least it used to be world of warcraft
nowadays the one true king isn't just
playing wow he's trying mmos of all
kinds
come on kill him kill him come on come
on please please please
point one
he is single-handedly the biggest taste
maker in the genre because his fans can
count on him to always offer his
unfiltered opinion even if it's a
negative one about their favorite game
how is it that the game designers are
unable to come up with better solutions
than a bunch of angry neckbeards on a
forum he hasn't quit wow if anything wow
has kind of quit him ah
blizzard
are you kidding me
are you [ __ ] kidding me
is this a joke but he's continued to
grow in popularity and he showed that
he's more than just a wow streamer and
as his fans come out in droves for
whatever game he's playing that day
asthman gold isn't slowing down and if
you don't like that well it is what it
is and people call me a [ __ ] and you
know what that's fine with me i always
say what i think
[Music]
before he became the one true king of
world of warcraft the streamer you now
know as asmongold made his living at the
irs and sam's club back then and to this
day he resides in austin texas where he
lives with and supports his mom he went
to school to get a business degree and
was contemplating law school until he
decided to focus on world of warcraft a
friend introduced him to the game when
he was 16 in july 2006 and within a year
he convinced his mom to buy the first
expansion
and pretty soon he was hooked i didn't
know what to expect
all i knew was that i was gonna play all
night and all day as much as i could as
much as possible it didn't take long for
the game to become his obsession
spending hours grinding away and
leveling with friends on his own or even
with his mom and so my mom and i went
together
into the burning crusade into hellfire
peninsula and we did all the quests
together at the very beginning
and we leveled up
and we got all that stuff done
and in 2009 asman gold uploaded his
first world of warcraft video to youtube
a five-minute recording of a warrior
soloing hakar
in glorious 480p in the early days like
a lot of wow creators his channel was
mostly game guides and how to's which he
was motivated to do after finding that a
lot of what was out there wasn't as
informative as he would have liked it's
your boy asman gold
and today we're gonna be talking about
i'm gonna be talking about something big
i've wanted to make a video about this
for a while
and i actually did but it sucked so
we're redoing it hopefully it won't suck
as much it's about how to get
achievements not not how to get any
specific achievements but the mindset
that it takes and the way you need to
set your goals as his youtube channels
began to grow and started to see
significant subscriber numbers streaming
became the obvious next step for
asmingold and he set up his stream in
2014. i moved over to making streaming
my main platform i feel like streaming
in a lot of ways
has a lot more growth potential than
youtube does in terms of like the
ceiling at first he struggled with
finding a consistent schedule and
building his audience the asmr gold
struggle right at the very beginning of
streaming that was a grind
that was a [ __ ] grind then he hit a
roadblock when he got suspended on
twitch after making an offensive joke
about hurricane katrina and a lot of the
displaced people from hurricane katrina
went to my high school and they would
all wear the same t-shirts and they were
animals every single one of them
honestly
the hurricane could have done a better
job
after some discussion with a twitch
employee he was able to start again and
even became a partner his following grew
steadily as one of the only wow
streamers that was able to capture the
audience's attention with his knowledge
of lore gameplay raids and his constant
candid conversation
like anybody that does like to chewing
tobacco like how the [ __ ] do you start
doing that like i understand like you
get addicted to nicotine and then it is
what it is but how do you like what's
the first time whenever you see somebody
doing that and they they spit out this
disgusting brown glob that looks like
microwaved cat [ __ ] and you think to
yourself that's what i want to do
that's me from the beginning asmingold
has been unashamedly himself he was the
og wow nerd in his messy room who played
and loved the game for all the same
reasons as his audience people fell in
love with his streams because he was
real and said the things that they were
thinking but sometimes that realness got
him into trouble there was never a
subject too spicy too normy or too
controversial for him to share his take
on whenever i say things like i don't
care about girls having only fans and
stuff like that
i could very easily say
the popular thing that people say i
could very easily say i think girls
should be able to do it but i wouldn't
be comfortable with my girlfriend doing
it that is the popular thing to say but
i don't say that because it's not what i
believe
and people call me a [ __ ] and you know
what that's fine with me in many ways
asman blazed the trail for what is now
the archetypical super streamer he was
able to pair chilling eating grinding
solo content in game and talking [ __ ]
with the kind of constant social
commentary we've now come to expect from
the platform asman views himself as a
personality streamer and believes that
the gameplay is almost secondary to the
commentary he provides the today
is no ordinary stream
today
whoa
ladies and gentlemen the doors to castle
matria will not open themselves he's
been known to fire off an opinion with
little thought and as his platform has
grown so has his internet megaphone the
same megaphone that's gotten him in
trouble i had no problem talking about
issues that i really felt like were bad
i called out the entire community
whenever olyny had that thing happen and
everybody was against me recently a
tweet referencing the sinatra sexual
violence allegations landed him in hot
water and then there was his take that
shadowland's prequel novel writer
madeline rue had engaged in reverse
racism in a series of tweets as well as
his refusal to stop using an ableist
slur that was a big point of contention
online i think there's nothing wrong
with saying the word return and i think
that the people that get mad about it
are just [ __ ] stupid and i'm gonna
keep saying it until they tell me that i
can't if i if i say it they'll ban me
right now obviously if i if i can't say
it i won't say it but until then i'm
gonna keep saying it because i don't
think there's anything wrong with it and
i think the people that are getting mad
about it are just stupid but most of all
has been gold is known best for his
critical views on blizzard overall and
the specific gameplay and lore gaps in
world of warcraft asmangold has always
loved the game he's given most of his
adult life to it but as more expansions
have been released it seemed like it was
getting harder and harder to keep loving
when warlords of draenor got released
asmingold felt that blizzard was
creating a barrier for any new players
looking to play he felt that the
expansion was going out of its way to
remove ways to make friends in game now
i can do a hundred battlegrounds and i
can be top damage and i can just never
die and it could be super awesome and i
can just kick ass but i will never have
as much fun as i did you know killing
the yeti with my friends you know
hanging out having fun and i think that
the game has streamlined so many
different aspects that it's hard to
really make those connections his vocal
opinions led to a complicated
relationship with blizzard with very
public and heated clashes who do you
think
contributes more to the toxicity in the
game
do you think it is the person who
streams the game
or the person who literally makes the
systems in the game have i been toxic in
the past absolutely
have i done some things that are toxic
absolutely
i take no uh i don't hide from that in
fact i talk about it regularly it's who
i was
and in a way it's still who i am
i don't pretend however do you want to
know what real pretending seems like
it seems like taking slash spit out of
the game while you let people say the n
word you don't care about harassment
you don't care about toxicity
you care about protecting the feelings
of your whales at blizzcon in 2018
asmongold was told he could not be in
another player's stream and was asked to
leave the stage i went to stream with
sfond
and
they told me that i couldn't be on
camera with him and like as soon as i
walked up there
they were like there was like three
[ __ ] dudes or there was one guy that
was like really mad and he was like this
i couldn't hear what he was saying right
but he wasn't [ __ ] happy about it and
they came up there and they told me i
had to leave
so i don't know i i didn't like that at
all and things have only gotten worse in
recent years during battle for azeroth
and shadowlands i feel like a lot of the
blizzard developers genuinely do not
play world of warcraft the same way that
their players do and i think that's
evident by the amount of changes that
the developers add into the game there
are either changes that have been asked
before by the very highest degree of pvp
players or pve players because those are
the people who have the ear of the
developers or on the other side changes
that are just completely antithetical to
what an mmo is supposed to be the
mounting issues with the game have been
tough for asman to cope with more and
more it felt less like the game he grew
up on i've only really ever cared about
this game
i just i don't see it getting better
it's just somehow getting worse every
single time
i'm just tired of it the state of
california filing a lawsuit against
activision blizzard really brought
everything into perspective for asman
making it hard to want to stream wow or
even play music from the game while
streaming
really affected me it's it's bothered me
to be honest i feel like as a uh you
know almost 25 years now i've played
blizzard games i started in warcraft 2.
and uh to read this you feel betrayed
you feel like those moments and those
experiences that you've had
now are under the context of these
things happening at the expense of other
people and they feel less pure and less
real and less less just good
and
it makes the memories tainted and it
makes the experience tainted as well in
recent years retail wow has tended to
flounder but for years many community
figures have pushed for a wow classic
server to let them relive their early
wow glory days and asmongold was one of
the biggest voices leading that charge
and though blizzard fought back
have you ever thought about adding
servers for previous expansions as they
were then no
and by the way you don't want to that to
do that either you think you do but you
don't
eventually the scene got what they
wanted a vanilla server and
gold's stream
popped off well i'm in i mean
this is it boys this is [ __ ] it man
all right let's go i welcome you all
to the very beginning
of our glorious guild
the guild is called olympus
because we are liberal gods day one of
streaming classic wow aswing gold hit
263
720 viewers at one time it was like the
release was a made for him
you do not fight with honor bargoth
but hey at least you fight to the death
over the years has been gold has seen
streamers come and go and he's always
been thankful for the level of success
he has achieved but success hasn't
really changed him he's still the same
dude sitting in a messy room with the
lights off talking about games asmingold
has found that living simply and being
able to support his mom is what makes
him happiest i live the most extravagant
great life i could possibly ever imagine
i'm surrounded by my friends that i
spend time with daily i have a great
thing that i do with my streams and my
videos i consider myself incredibly
lucky and i'm very passionate about that
in many ways and he doesn't just spend
his money on his family in october 2020
one of his goals became a reality when
he decided to put his business degree to
use and create one true king a content
organization he put together with some
of his regular streaming buddies and a
few newbies i announced my new org otk
one true king with uh rich campbell tips
out s band and mischief
i still cannot even believe that it's
happened i can't believe the amount of
feedback and great support that we've
gotten it quickly became one of the
biggest streaming orgs with over 25
million hours watched and otk wasn't the
only change in the past year through otk
asman has been doing more on his streams
like playing fall guys and having a
dungeons and dragons campaign with his
fellow streamers recently he's shifted
focus from wow to final fantasy xiv a
big change for someone who has almost
exclusively been interested in playing
wow for the last 15 years i'm not
quitting well i really enjoy wow as well
but it's been great to be able to play
something different and to have a
different perspective on the game i'm
just having a good time i'm having i'm
enjoying myself it's fun i'm playing the
game off stream and just trying to do
uh what i want to do and i've
missed that a lot
yes yes come on come on get him kill him
kill him yes
yes
yes
asmongold continues to be the mmo
everyman even if he isn't focusing on
world of warcraft right now he's still
bringing his expertise and opinions to
final fantasy 14. the social structures
in the game are a little bit off-putting
some of the ways that people are very
pushy and evangelize their game is a
little bit off-putting as well however i
do really just want to play a good game
though he's playing a new game you can
bet that you'll always be able to find
asmin doing what he's always done
sitting in a dark messy room raiding
questing and hanging out on stream all
right ready here we go
holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] are you kidding me dude
are you
kidding me dude oh my god
oh my god dude
what a day
there may have been a time when world of
warcraft was the main event and asmin
gold was the vessel that was carrying
one of the most beloved games of all
time to its loyal following but that
time has come and gone the one true king
has outgrown any one game a lot of
people watch me for a while etc but if i
play another game i still have a large
audience of people who like seeing that
too and i think that's awesome and i
really appreciate that that's so [ __ ]
amazing i feel so lucky for that
honestly he's the voice for mmo players
grinders trolls twitch oh geez and react
andies everywhere a true twitch
tastemaker and there's no telling where
he'll go next i've enjoyed myself a lot
and i look forward to doing a lot more
so until next time boys
peace
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
[Music]